remember you need repetition and novelty
after a while if you're listening to the
same thing over and over again the brain
is picking up less and less and less hi
there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about listening
skills listening skills how to get
better at listening how to use listening
to learn a language
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications so
as you know
i consider input listening and reading
to being to be the keys to learning a
language you have to get the language
into you it has to come from outside you
have to get your brain used to a new
language
this is best achieved through listening
and reading
reading helps you acquire more words
but listening gets your brain used to
the language and of course listening
comprehension is a tremendously
important skill because if you're
speaking to someone and we all want to
speak in the language if you can't
understand what they're saying what the
other person is saying then
it's very uncomfortable and you can't
have a very
meaningful conversation so how do you
use listening to get better in the
language and what are the
tips to get better at listening
first of all
it depends on each each person but i
cannot sit down and just listen if i
were to sit and i've tried it
so i have whatever lesson i'm listening
to and i sit down in a comfortable chair
and i say i'm going to spend half an
hour listening to this
podcast or whatever it might be i'm
incapable of doing that my mind mind
wanders so i can't concentrate
if i have dedicated
study time
then i'm going to read or i'm going to
work on my ipad with link
so where does the listing come in
listening has the tremendous advantage
that we can do it wherever we are i
don't have my air pods handy but
i have my airpods and i recently bought
a new kind of airpod that sits outside
the ear and they work really well i went
jogging yesterday
and i could hear very well and i don't
have these things actually plugged into
my ear
but i can listen first thing in the
morning i get up i have a little seven
minute exercise routine i listen i make
breakfast i listen
if i exercise during the day i listen if
i'm in the car i listen so you've got
all this time to listen all right
so then people say well when you're
listening do you always focus all right
it is impossible to 100 focus while
listening you have to like so much in
language learning you have to accept
imperfection
so when you speak you're going to make
mistakes when you listen there's going
to be lots of areas you don't understand
there are also going to be moments when
you are not focused on what you're
listening to you lose track you your
mind wanders off somewhere else that's
fine
as long as you come back and so let's
say for a period of 30 minutes that i'm
in the car listening to something maybe
i'm only focused on what i'm listening
to for
half that time or i don't know what the
number is because i don't worry about it
but i know it's not a hundred percent of
the time but for whatever percentage of
the time i'm listening i'm exposing my
brain to the language and i am
getting used to the language
now one of the things that's very
important is you cannot continue to
listen to
your target language and not understand
anything or only understand five percent
that is very inefficient in my
experience so if i listen to something
obviously at the early stages in the
language i don't understand anything but
then i will read it i will look up the
words i'll review them in link
read it again then i'll listen and i
still don't understand even though i
understood kind of when i was reading
and looking up words when i go to listen
i don't understand but that doesn't
bother me i know that from personal
experience that in time what initially
is just noise for me by a process of
reading and listening and going back and
reading again and looking up words again
and listening again eventually more and
more of this becomes comprehensible
don't listen to the same lesson over and
over and over again at one sitting in
other words
the brain as i've said many times
requires repetition and novelty so you
can listen to an item a few times then
move on to the next item even if you
don't fully understand the first so you
have lesson one
and you listen and you listen and you
read it then you listen again and you
understand twenty thirty percent move on
to the next one don't try to you know
master any particular lesson or content
item it's all exposure it's all helping
the brain get used to the language
remember you need repetition and novelty
after a while if you're listening to the
same thing over and over again the brain
is picking up less and less and less
so you have to move to the next lesson
and to the next lesson so keep pushing
yourself forward maintain that balance
between repetition and novelty
and there's all kinds of research into
how the brain learns that sort of block
learning that third fourth fifth time we
read something or we listen to something
we are in fact learning less and less so
you have to keep moving forward
now so don't worry about losing focus
don't worry about what you don't
understand
keep challenging or rewarding your brain
with new material but do have enough
repetition so that you start to notice
certain things that you didn't notice
the first time and this is the next
point about listening
i can listen to a mini story that i've
listened to 30 40 times before so i know
the mini story
and yet i will suddenly notice a
structure
a verb pattern verb form that i hadn't
really noticed before even though i knew
the rule vaguely but
the 31st time that i listened to that i
notice it in a different way so give
yourself a chance to notice things
when you go back for that additional
pass through the same material so you're
again you're maintaining that repetition
and novelty but when you're on your in
your repetition
activity allow yourself to notice
certain things you don't have to notice
everything you can lose focus but there
will be times when you notice
certain things in there that will help
you in your gradual acquisition of the
language and remember that listening
comprehension here is the goal
it's not going to be perfect but it will
gradually improve and the better your
listening comprehension the better your
ability to have conversations but
again
give yourself you know a variety between
repetition repetitious material and new
challenging material combine reading
with listening
try to focus in on certain aspects of
pronunciation that you maybe didn't
notice before
be aware that some of the things that
you didn't notice on the first time
listening or the second or the fifth or
the tenth time you may notice the 20th
time you listen so the the process of
acquisition of a language is gradual so
if you listen and you don't understand
don't get frustrated if you listen and
read and listen and read and still don't
understand don't get frustrated that's
normal
and
at least in my own case i prefer to be
listening and doing something else
cleaning up the garage whatever it might
be
listening fading out
focusing in again
that works better for me than trying to
sit down and say okay for the next half
hour i'm to listen to this all right the
exception of that of course
is if you're watching a movie
which is a form of listening but you're
watching and listening at the same time
and it's rewarding because it's fun to
watch a movie and you can see the people
you can almost feel as if you're
participating with this family that's
why series you know on netflix are so
great if it's if it's the same group of
people interacting all the time in the
series and you watch them and you feel
you're a part of them and you're getting
that sense of being in that cultural
you know uh sphere
um all of that is good
but
i wouldn't
you know i consider the the sort of
video movies tv series that's more of a
reward that's fun you have to develop
the ability to be able to listen
without seeing what's going on
uh
initially sort of repetitious material
like the many stories eventually
audiobooks
where just hearing the words conjures up
meaning for you so that you're
automatically converting you know words
in the target language into meaning and
so as you build up to that
level of of listening comprehension you
are preparing yourself to become fluent
in the language so that's my advice
treat listening
and listening comprehension not only as
a
primary goal in language learning
but as an important way of helping your
brain become accustomed to the language
so i hope that was
helpful
thank you for listening